nous sommes avec stéphane rozès
président de cap conseil analyse et
perspective politologue enseignant à
sciences po et hec avec nous également
florian philippot président des
patriotes bonsoir messieurs merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
une réaction plus générale peut-être
pour commencer le président a dit ne pas
changer le cap mais prendre je cite un
nouveau chemin vous l'avez trouvé clerc
pour expliquer ce nouveau chemin
stéphane rozès il a pu être décevant
dans la mesure où cette interview était
très attendue au fond après une période
social marqué par les mouvements défi
des chaulnes des retraites
évidemment de crise sanitaire de très
grande ampleur inusuelles et en amont
d'un choc économique et social le
président nous avait annoncé un nouveau
chemin dont on a peine à voir au fond la
cohérence ou la nouveauté dans la mesure
où le président a fait surtout amergoul
pas de former pas véritablement de fond
il n'a pas expliqué les raisons
profondes de la dépression française
manour est activé du délitement de son
lien avec la nation par contre il a
annoncé évidemment des mesures mais le
pays est sans doute restée sur sa faim
il y avait là une occasion
exceptionnelle dans le moment
exceptionnel que nous connaissons et je
dirais que l'intervention qui a duré
pendant une heure vingt à manquer sans
doute de vision de souffle eu de
diagnostic profond de sorte que le
président semble par différentes mesures
essayer de colmater une situation
difficile sans que véritablement le pays
a une perspective de moyen et de long
terme puisque c'est ça qui avait été
annoncé par le président macron florian
philippot un manque de vision
malgré l'annoncé d'un nouveau chemin
également selon vous c'est à dire qu'il
a annoncé un nouveau chemin mais j'ai
pas très bien compris en quoi le nouveau
chemin était différent de l'ancien
chemin
bon si ce n'est qu' on traversera le
nouveau chemin avec un masque il est
bien suivi mais je vois pas la
différence au delà de ça moi ce qui m'a
frappé dans cette interview c'est que
d'abord le la glorification de son
supposé bilan très qu'ovide cirque on a
eu le sentiment à l'écouté aujourd'hui
qu' il n'y a pas eu de chance il ya eu
le corona les russes mais qu'avant tout
était en merveilleuse voix ses terres
qu'il est en train de résoudre le
problème du chômage il était en train de
régler comme il le fallait le premier
déficit point de la pauvreté de ça mais
je crois que les français ont un tout
petit peu de mémoire se souviennent du
monde datant d'avant confinement ce
n'était pas tout à fait comme ça que ça
se passe et les résultats n'étaient pas
là la politique était très injuste il y
avait déjà beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
désordres sociaux de manifestations et
mobilisations
je crois que chacun s'en souvient la
soul est on est on est frappé par une
crise absolument historique on va voir
une récession de dispense 12 % d'après
les plus grandes instances économiques
et on se dit mais qu'est ce qui va
changer
ben on était rien ne va changer et on va
vie pour une raison simple c'est qu'on
ne reste en même temps on reste dans
l'union européenne on reste dans l'euro
donc on va appliquer les mêmes
politiques et est donc macro et bien
impuissant à dire ce qu'il peut changer
parce qu'ils ne peuvent rien changer et
civils et n'a pas les grands instruments
de souveraineté pour changer la
politique de la france alors il joue sur
deux trois détails de 3 mesurettes mais
fondamentalement il va mener demain la
même politique qui la meule et fière
parce que la france n'a plus les grands
instruments de souveraineté du fait
qu'elle appartient à l'union européenne
et à l'euro pour changer sa politique
et c'est bien là de l'un des drames de
notre pays va bien falloir un jour qu'on
affronte ce problème la bille en tête
alors le chef de l'état qui a commencé
par s'exprimer sur ce qu'ils percevaient
des tas de l'esprit du pays ont regardé
et vous réagissez ensuite notre pays au
fonds a peur et à une crise de confiance
confiance à l'égard de lui même regardez
la période récente que nous venons de
franchir
si nous nous écoutions nous mêmes on
faisait moins bien que les voisins nous
étions les pires quand on commence à
regarder le bilan non
loin d'être les pires mais nous avons en
quelque sorte un doute permanent sur
nous mêmes en tant que pays alors est ce
que vous le rejoignez si on écoutait
nous serions les pires nous traversons
une crise de confiance des fans rozès je
suis d'accord avec le diagnostic ya nous
sommes les plus pessimistes au monde
avec un ou deux pays en situation
économique et sociale très difficile est
selon moi la dépression française n'a
pas tant une raison économique et social
car notre modèle social quoique très
dégradée demeure enviable et enviés par
rapport à d'autres pays y compris les
pays voisins mais à des raisons
culturelles
c'est à dire que la france notre nation
pour se déployer a besoin de ce proche
jeter dans l'espace et le temps or notre
état néolibéral est enclavée au
contraire dans des politiques
européennes procédurale de nature
économique et c'est cette contradiction
qui faible dépression or emmanuel macron
si pendant un an il a pu réformer le
pays alors même que des français
estimaient ces réforme injuste
économiquement et socialement c'est que
comme il l'avait dit c'était fait ou non
de la restauration de la souveraineté de
la nation il avait dit devant le congrès
le premier mandat que m'ont confié les
français c'est la restauration de la
souveraineté de la nation aura un an
après son élection
après que la chancelière merkel des
privés d'une deuxième étape de son
mouvement
il appert à tête à queue silencieux et
là c'est l'achat créé des fils à jo
c'est à dire qu'il a raison sur le
constat mais il ne va pas au fond de
l'explication tient que justement la
politique qui a été menée
facialement moi en tout cas sa
justification
un an après son élection ça a été au
fond pour les français une reprise à peu
près de des politiques de ses
prédécesseurs et donc c'est l'homme
ne va pas au bout du chemin si je peux
me permettre c'est à dire que le constat
est juste mais il ne dit pas les
éléments de nature comité dont il est au
premier chef le responsable où le
tracteur pour expliquer justement cette
dépression et cette contradiction entre
une situation économique et sociale
encore par rapport à nos voisins on
viable et enviée et une dépression du
pays un lien débuté entre le président
et la nation florian philippon comment
fait-on alors pour surmonter cette crise
de confiance diagnostiqué par le
président emmanuel macron une question à
se poser est comment voulez vous que le
peuple français est pleinement confiance
dans son propre pays qu'en depuis 40 ans
je crois que ça a commencé avec le
valéry giscard d'estaing s'est pas tout
à fait raison
les élites à la tête du pays ne passent
leur vie à expliquer aux français que
leur pays de façon n'a pas d'avenir
qu'ils ne représentent pas grand chose
des giscard qu'ils ont nés que 1% de la
population mondiale
on est depuis sans ce moyenne et puis
ensuite mitterrand a ajouté que certes
la france était notre patrie mais que
notre avenir c'est l europe
sous-entendu la france n'est même pas
notre avenir et puis et puis on a ajouté
toutes les politiques et traités etc
jusqu'à macron et est maintenant par le
même en permanence de souveraineté
européenne sous-entendu il peut même pu
y avoir de souveraineté nationale réelle
comment voyez vous que le peuple
français les confiance quand il voit à
ses chefs ne pas avoir confiance
manifestement dans le pays dans sa
capacité à être un pays libre pays
souverain et avoir un avenir propre
je crois que le malaise des réside la
clé réside là le jour où on aura des
chefs des présidents des prémices des
chefs de gouvernements qui auront
vraiment l'amour et la confiance de la
france
la confiance en la france alors ils
auront la confiance du peuple français
mais aujourd'hui ça n'est pas possible
de croire dans un pays si le les chefs
de ce pays eux-mêmes ne croient pas dans
le pays et c'est ce qui est bien c'est
ce qu'il ne cesse de transférer notre
souveraineté à des instances
supranationales
c'est donc l'élu pense que la france ne
peut pas le faire elle même
et je crois que la contradiction le
malaise il est bien profondément delà du
sens une nation très politique
une nation qui s'est battu toute sa vie
même l'essence de la force pour sa
liberté prend son indépendance
à partir du moment où on lui explique
que ce n'est plus possible et bien c'est
prêcher nouvelle dépression on est en
dépression nationale et ça ne peut pas
s'arranger
tant qu'on ne change pas de logiciel et
macro nous avions annoncé aujourd'hui
une rupture il va nous c'est la
continuité malheureusement en tout
l'état il a pris ses responsabilités on
aurait pu entendre à son mea culpa je
n'ai pas réussi à réconcilier les
français j'ai donné le sentiment qu'au
fond je réforme est pour eux où malgré
eux et qui n'était pas juste je n'ai pas
assez montré un chemin de justice
il a aussi pris acte de la détestation
contre lui en déplorant la haine
notamment celles qu'il perçoit dans les
manifestations comment est ce que vous
avez reçues ces déclarations stéphane
rozès je les ai reçus comme juste budget
ctive mans mais au fond emmanuel mâcon
semble dire au pays que il faudrait en
passer par là qu'il prendrait sur ses
épaules ce poids qu'il faudrait payer
comme si l'alternative du pays était
pour survivre d'en passer par là
or il y à un imaginaire français qui
date de quelques siècles
et lorsque la crise pandémique arrive
puisque une pandémie pose la question de
la vie et de la mort individuelles et
collectives
kosa question de qu'est-ce qu'une
communauté nationale
on a vu le président revenir à des
fondamentaux de notre imaginaire il a
utilisé le terme de souveraineté
nationale de modèle social
puis il a parlé de souveraineté
nationale souveraineté européenne puis
dans la dernière déclaration
d'indépendance nationale et maintenant
on n'entend plus effectivement de
perspectives de nature politique
or le propos qui est le mien n'est pas
celui d'un politologue s'intéressant ou
dimension anthropologique de la nation
c'est que il faut bien comprendre que
nous allons subir nous subissons une
crise de l'offre et de la demande et que
la dépression morales et politiques
empêchent les consommateurs et ménages
de limiter départ de précaution en
consommant et empêche les chefs
d'entreprise investir en un mot le
défaut de vision du président en fait
n'est pas du tout une incitation pour
les français acteur et agents
économiques de prendre un pari sur
l'avenir car justement le président se
contentent d'acter ce qui dysfonctionne
ray sans dire l'essentiel pour les
français c'est là où il amènerait la
france comme si la france devait sans
cesse choisir entre la survie et au fond
le renoncement à peser or c'est là où le
président mâcon est très étonnant c'est
que contrairement à ses prédécesseurs il
met beaucoup plus des mots sur le
constat de la dépression mais en fait
derrière ils n'en tirent pas de leçons
comme s'ils se contentaient de constater
que pour l'heure comme n'aurait pas
d'opposants crédibles et réalistes
il pourrait continuer ainsi avec le pays
c'est selon moi très bon cru les gilets
jaunes ont montré c'était selon moi une
jacquerie de sorte que le président
n'est pas un auteur politique ce n'est
qu'un acteur d'un moment et d'une
situation et je trouve qui a là une
occasion perdue
c'est à dire que lors de la
présidentielle il y avait pour lui une
occasion de construire quelque chose de
neuf
après des villages où il ya une deuxième
occasion de d'apt et des choses et de
compte
dire quelque chose de neuf et là j'ai le
regret de constater qu'au fond il ya une
troisième occasion qui n'a pas permis au
président au fond de faire une confiance
exclusive dans notre génie et dans
l'intelligence les français florian
philippot mea culpa un simple constat
c'est ce que vous retenez vous aussi de
cette prise de parole ce matin
oui oui objectivement un mea culpa
extrêmement extrêmement léger parce que
parce qu'on voit bien que tout de suite
il précise que le problème c'était pas
tant le son que la méthode on va tout ça
je pense que ça ne trompe plus grand
monde
s'il se plaint de la détestation dont il
compte il est la victime
peut-être devrait-il se demander s'il
n'a pas en boomerang est ce qu il a semé
si vous voulez quand on a passé sa il a
passé beaucoup de arue le fait moins
maintenant parce que parce que c'est ça
le plus possible et sa nature profonde
c'était quand même d'être
particulièrement méprisant avec les
français et on a même oublié toutes les
séquences mais quand il parlait des
alcooliques quand il parlait des gens
qui ne sont rien quand il a parlé même
dès le début la crise et gilet jaune il
avait dit à la télévision c'était une
foule haineuse violences sont pas des
mots très agréable sont pas des mêmes
des mots très responsable quand on est
chef d'état on ne parle pas comme ça de
son propre peuple
quoi qu'on pense d'engouement populaire
ou sociale on doit bien se garder de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu or c'est ce
qu'il a fait car je crois par
tempérament même personnel et est envoyé
par faute politique
donc en contrepartie en boomerang il
s'est pris effectivement eu de haine
populaire assez assez massive et il en
est aujourd'hui la victime mais elle est
victime en réalité que justement de ce
qu'il a semé lui même pour le reste non
j'ai pas vu de perspectives j'ai pas vu
une nouveauté je me souviens des grands
discours du début de confinement où on
allait voir ce qu'on allait voir il
avait compris beaucoup de choses il
allait lui même il allait lui-même se
remettre en cause et puis ils allaient
nous faire des annonces quasiment
civilisationnel à la sortie en sortie de
crise
et bien il n'en est rien resté
aujourd'hui il restera le bon petit
soldat de l'union européenne le bon
petit soldat de l'européisme et du
mondialisme et donc ils continuent de
dérouler la feuille
août que bruxelles berlin et quelques
autres plus horrifique
dès lors il faut florian philippot des
mesures pour la jeunesse néanmoins qui
ont été annoncées s'ils voulaient des
mesures pour la jeunesse je crois que la
jeunesse attend avant tout qu'on lui
offre une espérance et un navire donc de
ce point de vue là je crois qu'il ya une
vraie un vrai manque parmi la jeunesse
de france n'a pas eu de perspectives de
tracer dans la jeunesse elle va galérer
elle va essayer de trouver un emploi à
essayer de trouver un salaire décent à
essayer de s'en sortir de pouvoir se
loger de pouvoir vivre à peu près
dessalement et on n'est pas remis si
vous voulez aujourd'hui en france parmi
les premières générations où on commence
à se dire en fait on va vivre bien moins
bien que nos parents et ça c'était
pareil ça c'est une rupture
civilisationnel parce que ça faisait
longtemps qu'on avait pris l'habitude de
penser que les nouvelles générations
vivrait mieux que les précédentes ça
n'est plus le cas il est donc temps de
se remettre profondément en question est
venu remettre profondément en question
les choix politiques et idéologiques qui
ont été faits depuis des décennies alors
bien évidemment la crise sanitaire
également au coeur de l'interview et la
question du port du masque on regarde on
en parle après nous avons des signes que
ça repart quand même un peu face à cela
nous devons prévenir et nous préparer
prévenir
qu'est ce que c'est nous avons appris
pendant cette période nous avons appris
comment se transmettait ce virus mieux
qu'au début
la meilleure prévention ce sont ce qu'on
appelle les gestes barrière contre le
virus
les masques se tenir à distance et le
gel hydroalcoolique et donc il faut
continuer d'appliquer ces gestes
barrières là dessus on voit des
faiblesses donc j'ai demandé à ce qu'on
passe une étape au gouvernement et je
souhaite que dans les prochaines
semaines on rende obligatoire
le mas dans tous les lieux publics clos
on le sait dans les transports ça marche
très bien mais c'est un peu erratique
dans les lieux publics clos les
protocoles par exemple restaurant
fonctionne très bien doivent être
respectées mais dans les magasins selon
les magasins etc
ça veut dire qu'il faut que les choses
s'organisent pas de faire du jour au
lendemain je recommande à tous nos
concitoyens qui nous écoutent de porter
le masque au maximum quand ils sont
dehors et a fortiori quand ils sont dans
un lieu clos et nous allons on va
observer la situation nous mettre en
situation de pouvoir
par exemple à partir du 1er août le
rendre totalement obligatoire alors port
du masque obligatoire à partir du 1er
août donc il a également assuré qu'en
cas de seconde vague
tout était prêt pour conclure stéphane
rozès est-ce qu'on peut le croire
oui disons qu'elle très certainement le
sommet de l'état a eu le temps de mieux
se préparer au début de la pandémie
l'objectif pour le gouvernement et le
président c'est de faire en sorte que
l'impact de la crise soit la moins forte
sur le choc économique et social qui
arrivent huit cent mille chômeurs au
moins sont attendus les premiers indices
ont plutôt réconfortant ce serait
peut-être on serait peut-être dans la
moyenne basse mais vous voyez quand même
que le choc va être terrible terrible
terrible donc le président nos
compatriotes les sauts comme disait
darmana pour éteindre un incendie mais
au fond c'est à périmètre constant ne
change on voit pas de changement de
nature de la politique on voit que pour
l'allemagne et la france
heureusement pour quelque temps on ne va
pas trop être regardants sur la question
des déficits bon on verra d'ailleurs ce
que ça veut dire sur la réforme des
retraites
en tout cas la dimension budgétaire de
la réforme des retraites mais en amour
clairement pour l'exécutif
la priorité c'est faire en sorte que
l'impact récessif soit le moins fort
possible par rapport au risque de
reprise de la pandémie la question est
est ce que l'europe et la france font
suffisamment en termes de politiques
contracycliques ashton stéphane rozès
merci on va le c'est florian philippot
conclure en quelques mots à la fois sur
cette histoire de masques et puis ce
port de masque obligatoire à partir du
1er août
et puis un mot pour conclure sur cette
interview du président de la république
si vous voulez au moment où on avait
besoin des masques ne m'avait pas et on
nous expliquait que de façon ça ne
servait à rien et qu'on ne savait même
pas les porter ça c'était en février
mars
aujourd'hui quand même regarder les
courbes 1 parce qu'il faut pas regarder
simplement le nombre de cas au regard du
nombre d'hospitalisations c'est ça qui
compte ça voilà la courbe en france elle
reste plate
dieu merci là on me dirait masque
obligatoire dans les lieux clos
bon je crois qu'on va avoir un peu de
mal si vous voulez à comprendre je peux
faire vrai qu'on travaille sur le
traitement je préférerais que l'on
contrôle sérieusement nos frontières et
nos aéroports puisque ont cessé les
vocaux les journalistes qui l'ont
rapporté beaucoup des cas nouveau en
france sont des cas importés
il n'y a pas eu de contrôles aux
aéroports c'est la première chose qu'on
devrait cibler plutôt que en plein
milieu du mois va en plein milieu des
vacances d'été et au début août
d'imposer forcément le masque à tout le
monde sans discernement je sais pas je
sais pas si c'est la bonne stratégie je
trouve que je trouve que c'est un peu
facile de ne pas faire l'essentiel
frontières traitement c'est lui de faire
ce qu'il aurait dû être fait il ya six
mois et qui à l'époque n'a pas été fait
merci beaucoup à tous les deux merci à
vous florian philippot président là les
patriotes merci stéphane rozès président
de cap politologue et enseignant à
sciences po et hec